after wearing a face mask for the first
time
during a visit to his constituency boris
johnson has served notice
that masks could soon be compulsory in
shops in england
as they are now in scotland we need to
be
stricter in insisting that people wear
face coverings in
confined places where
um they are meeting people that they
know they don't
normally meet so that's why it's
mandatory already on
on public transport and uh we're looking
at ways of making sure
that people really do uh observe whether
you do have face coverings in
in in in shops for instance where you
know
there is a risk of transmission the
latest official data
suggests that just over half of us wore
a face covering
in the last week of june up nearly 10
from the week before even though
scientists have not
so far called for their widespread use
i think in other countries perhaps
they've gone beyond
the absolute proof of effectiveness and
have taken more of a kind of
precautionary
approach that you know we can't do any
harm
and may do some good and so it doesn't
surprise me that the
thinking might be moving in that
direction after months of near deserted
city centre streets
the prime minister has also said it's
time for people to end working from home
and get back to the office if they can
i think everybody's sort of taking the
stay at home if you can i think we
should now
so say well go back to work if you can
because i think it's very important that
people should
should try to lead their lives more
normally
mr johnson wants to persuade millions of
people to return to pre-lockdown work
patterns
and start spending again officials here
insist there's no
change in government guidance but the
prime minister's remarks
do reveal a change in tone no doubt
influenced by the almost
daily announcements of layoffs and shop
closures
from businesses that rely heavily on
custom from people
going to work good news for many today
is that as well as outdoor pools
reopening club cricket is back
the fort green cricket club near marple
in cheshire
they're getting ready for their first
game of the season this afternoon
but it's the economy that needs to get
on the front foot right now
why the pm is urging people to go back
to work
and proposing face masks to give them
the confidence
that it's safe to do so john craig
sky news